E
.
>> SO THERE YOU HAVE IT.
REPORTERS ARE SHOUTING
QUESTIONS.
WE DID SEE A HANDSHAKE, A PRETTY
SIGNIFICANT HANDSHAKE, CLARISSA,
FROM THE TWO LEADERS, THE
RUSSIAN PRESIDENT, THE U.S.
PRESIDENT, AND THE OPENING
STATEMENT FROM THE SWISS
PRESIDENT TRANSLATED IN BOTH
SWISS AND AMERICAN.
>> WELCOMING THEM AND HOPING FOR
PEACE NOT JUST FOR YOUR
COUNTRIES BUT THE ENTIRE WORLD.
I THINK THAT'S IMPORTANT TO LOOK
AT WHEN WE'RE LOOKING AT THE
SUMMIT.
THIS ISN'T JUST ABOUT THE U.S.
AND RUSSIA SITTING DOWN FOR A
CONVERSATION.
THIS IS ABOUT DEMOCRACIES
CHALLENGED BY AUTHORITARIAN
REGIMES.
MANY COUNTRIES ACROSS THE WORLD
WILL BE LOOKING TO SEE WHAT
HAPPENS TODAY, WHETHER ANYTHING
CAN BE TAKEN OUT OF IT AND
TURNED INTO SOMETHING
PRODUCTIVE.
>> THESE MOMENTS TURN INTO
MOMENTS.
I'LL TELL YOU ABOUT THE MOMENT
THERE.
THE HANDSHAKE, BIDEN LOOKED IN
THE EYE OF PUTIN WITH A SMILE
AND PUTIN LOOKED AWAY.
IT'S ABOUT PUBLIC POSTURING AND
NOTES STRENGTH.
>> WHO GOES FIRST, WHO EXTENDS
THEIR HAND FIRST.
>> BIDEN DID EXTEND.
>> WE WERE WAITING TO SEE IF
THERE WOULD BE THAT HANDSHAKE.
>> THERE WAS.
>> AND IT WAS A SIGNIFICANT
HANDSHAKE.
IT'S A GOOD WAY TO START THE
MEETING.
LET'S SEE WHAT HAPPENS OVER THE
NEXT FOUR OUR FIVE OR SIX HOURS.
>> AS SWISS PRESIDENT GUY
PARMELIN SAID, IT'S TIME TO DO
THE WORK.
>> AND THE DOOR IS CLOSE VRD
SYMBOLICALLY AND WE'RE LEFT TO
WONDER WHAT'S GOING TO GO ON IN
THOSE ROOM OVER THE NEXT FOUR TO
FIVE HOURS AND WHAT ROLE THEY
MAY HAVE IN RESHAPING OR
IMPROVING SOMEWHAT THE
RELATIONSHIP.
>> THEY BOTH DID GIVE A WAVE TO
THE JOURNALISTS WHO WERE
OUTSIDE, AND THE JOURNALISTS,
THAT'S THEIR JOB TO ASK
QUESTIONS.
THEY WERE SHOUTING QUESTIONS.
WE'RE NOT SURPRISED THEY WERE
NOT ANSWERED.
>> EXACTLY.
YOU KNOW ONE THING THAT WON'T
HAPPEN IN THE SUMMIT THAT
HAPPENED WHEN FORMER PRESIDENT
TRUMP MET PUTIN?
IS TEARING UP THE NOTES AFTER
THE MEETING.
YOU HAD MOMENTS LIKE THAT THAT
WERE EXTREMELY UNUSUAL UNDER THE
PRIOR PRESIDENT.
HERE, MUCH MORE PRO FORMA.
YOU WILL HAVE THE NOTETAKERS IN
THE ROOM, OVER DIPLOMATS
INVOLVED AT LEAST IN THE
EXPANDED SESSIONS, NOT THE
ONE-ON-ONE SESSIONS.
THAT'S SOMETHING THAT'S NOT
SIGNIFICANT, RETURNING TO
DIPLOMACY.
>> THE AUTHOR OF THE IMPORTANT
BOOK "JOE BIDEN: THE LIFE T RUN,
AND WHAT MATTERS NOW."
THANKS FOR JOINING US.
GIVE US YOUR THOUGHTS AS THE
PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED STATES
GOES INTO THIS MEETING WITH THE
PRESIDENT OF RUSSIA?
>> ONE THING THEY LEARN IS HE
BELIEVES DIPLOMACY IS DOMESTIC
AFFAIRS, DOMESTIC POLICIES.
GRILLS HIS ADVISERS SOMETIMES TO
THE POINT OF EXHAUSTION AS TO
WHAT IT IS THAT'S ON THE MIND OF
FOREIGN LEADER THEY'RE SITTING
DOWN WITH, WHAT ARE THEIR
PRIORITIES, THEIR FEARS, THE
PRESSURES BEARING DOWN ON THEM
IN THEIR OWN DOMESTIC POLITICS.
HE HAS SOMETIMES IRRITATED
DIPLOMATS IN THE PAST.
HE'LL TELL ME AND I'LL SAY IT
DOESN'T MAKE SENSE.
I NEED TO CONVEY TO THE PERSON
ACROSS THE TABLE WHAT EXACTLY
THE ISSUES ARE.
IN THIS CASE, BIDEN HAS FEELINGS
OF STRENGTH AND VULNERABILITY.
YOU'VE GOT HIGH OIL PRICES AND
YOU SEE HIM CRACKING DOWN ON
DESCENT, SO HE'S DEALING WITH A
COUNTERPARTY HERE TODAY WHO CAN
GO EITHER WAY IN THE SENSE HE
CAN EITHER BE ACTING OUT OF A
SENSE OF FEELING EMPOWERED OR BE
LOOKING FOR THOSE MOMENTS THAT
MIGHT SHORE HIM UP ON THE
FOREIGN STAGE.
BUT WHAT I THINK YOU JUST SAW IN
THAT MOMENT, THAT SORT OF KEY
FIRST PUBLIC ENCOUNTER IN THEIR
NEW ROLES AS PRESIDENT BIDEN, OF
COURSE, THEY MET BEFORE, WAS AN
EFFORT OF LET'S START THIS IN
THE SPIRIT OF WHAT JOE BIDEN
WOULD DESCRIBE AS THE
POSSIBILITY OF GETTING SOMETHING
DOWN.
THAT REFLECTS HOW HE OPERATES IN
WASHINGTON AND HOW HE OPERATES
ON THE WORLD STAGE.
>> AND HE DOES BELIEVE, AND I'VE
COVERED HIM AND YOU'VE COVERED
HIM FOR A LONG TIME.
HE DOES BELIEVE IN A DIALOGUE, A
DIALOGUE EVEN WITH ADVERSARIES.
AND MAYBE NOTHING WILL COME OF
IT.
MAYBE SOMETHING WILL COME OF IT.
BUT HE WANTS TO HAVE A SERIOUS
CONVERSATION WITH THE RUSSIAN
LEADER, RIGHT?
>> HE DOES.
LOOK.
HE REGARDS THIS AS THE BEGINNING
OF A PROCESS.
THIS IS BY NO MEANS THE END OF
IT.
IN FACT, HE THINKS THIS IS
REALLY ABOUT WHAT WE CAN SEE AS
A SOEFGT TERMS OF ENGAGEMENT.
THIS IS A NEW PRESIDENT WHO'S
NOT GOING TO PARTICIPATE IN SOME
OF THE SPECTACLE THAT VLADIMIR
PUTIN WAS ABLE TO ENLIST DONALD
TRUMP IN OVER THE LAST FOUR
YEARS.
HE'S MAKING IT CLEAR.
LOOK AT THE PEOPLE IN THE ROOM
WHO HE'S WITH IN THE MEETING.
THESE ARE ALL SERIOUS
PRACTITIONERS WITH A LOT OF
EXPERIENCE IN EUROPE.
TOREY KNEW LAND, TONY BLINKEN
WHO HAS BEEN AS CLOSE TO JOE
BIDEN AS EVERY.
ONE PERSON WHO'S NOT IN THE ROOM
BUT WHO IS PLAYING AN IMPORTANT
ROLE IS THE CIA DIRECTOR, BILL
BURNS.
HE'S BEEN A KEY PART OF THE
PREPARATION FOR THIS PROCESS,
AND BILL BURNS, WHO WAS THE U.S.
AMBASSADOR TO RUSSIA FROM 2005
TO 2008 IS ONE OF THE PEOPLE WHO
HAS HELPED SHAPE AMERICA'S
UNDERSTANDING HOW PUTIN THINKS,
UNDERSTANDING THE KREMLIN IS AS
MUCH ABOUT POLICY AS POLITICS.
THAT'S THE POWER HE'S GOING INTO
THE ROOM WITH.
WHAT'S HAPPENING IN THE WORLD
BUT WHAT'S HAPPENING BETWEEN
VLADIMIR PUTIN'S EARS.
THAT AS MUCH A PART OF THE
PROCESS.
>> WE'RE TOLD HE'S SPENT RECENT
DAYS, PRESIDENT BIDEN,
REVIEWING, GOING THROUGH
BACKGROUND BRIEFINGS, SPEAKING
WITH ALL THE TOP RUSSIAN EXPERTS
IN THE U.S. GOVERNMENT AND SOME
FROM OUTSIDE THE U.S.
GOVERNMENT, GETTING A BETTER
SENSE OF WHAT FOEBL ANTICIPATE
DURING THAT SUMMIT WITH PUTIN,
RIGHT?
>> YEAH.
THE OTHER PEOPLE HE'S BEEN
TALKING TO, OF COURSE, OVER THE
LAST WEEK ARE SOME OF THE
FOREIGN LEADERS HE ENCOUNTERED
AT THE G7 AND NATO MEETING,
ANGELA MERKEL, THE GERMAN
CHANCELLOR HAVING AS CLOSE A
RELATIONSHIP OR AS CLEAR AN
UNDERSTANDING OF VLADIMIR PUTIN
AS ANYBODY IN EUROPEAN
LEADERSHIP TODAY.
WE KNOW THEY SPOKE ABOUT HOW HE
SHOULD THINK ABOUT THIS MEETING.
HE ALSO HAS BEEN GOING BACK, AS
WE TALKED ABOUT, HIS EXPERIENCE
IN THE SOVIET UNION AND IN
RUSSIA IS SUBSTANTIAL AND
SPECIFIC.
IF YOU GO BACK TO 1979 WHEN HE
MADE A TRIP TO THE SOVIET UNION,
ONE OF THE PATTERNS WE BEGAN TO
SEE IS BIDEN IS VERY COMFORTABLE
IN TELLING PEOPLE CLEARLY IF HE
THINKS THEY'RE NOT TELLING HIM
THE TRUTH.
IN THAT MEETING HE FAMOUSLY USED
A FOUR-LETTER WORD TO CHALLENGE
HIS RUSSIAN.
HE ASKED THE TRANSLATOR HOW TO
TRANSLATE THAT AND HE SAID NOT
LITERALLY.
HE HAS A REPUTATION FOR PUTTING
PEOPLE A LITTLE OFF BALANCE.
BIDEN BELIEVES THERE CAN BE
BALANCE WITH THAT PARTICULARLY
IF THERE'S A DIP MOE MATIC MISS,
THAT LETS THE OTHER PERSON KNOW
YOU'RE ONTO THEM AND YOU'RE
THINKING CLEARLY ABOUT WHAT
THEY'RE DOING OUT IN THE WORLD.
I THINK YOU CAN ASSUME HE'S GONE
INTO THIS FULLY LOADED.
HE KNOWS THE SHORT-TERM AND
LONG-TERM ISSUES.
THE KEY POINT TO TAKE AWAY,
WOLF, THIS SOUTHBOUND HIM TRYING
TO UNDERSTAND WHAT'S GOING ON IN
VLADIMIR PUTIN'S MIND.
IS THIS ABOUT RUSSIA GENUINELY
TRYING TO ARREST THIS DOWNWARD
SPIRAL IN U.S. RELATIONS, OR IS
THIS JUST ABOUT PUTIN TRYING TO
ACHIEVE SOME MEASURE OF
VISIBILITY ON THE PUBLIC STAGE.
THAT'S THE KEY DETERMINATION FOR
THEM.
IF THEY SEE AN OPPORTUNITY TO
TRY TO ACTUALLY BUILD SOMETHING
AS THEY SAY MORE STABLE AND
PREDICTABLE, THAT'S THE WATCH
WORD OF THE WEEK, I THINK YOU
CAN EXPECT TO SEE THAT INDICATED
IN WHAT COMES OUT OF THE
MEETING, MAYBE THE BEGINNING OF
A DIALOGUE ABOUT STRATEGIC
STABILITY.
THAT'S GOING TO BE A SIGN
THEY'LL SENSE FROM PUTIN THEY
WANT TO DO DIFFERENT, BUT THEY
DON'T KNOW GOING INTO IT.
>> YOU MAKE AN IMPORTANT POINT.
PRESIDENT BIDEN GOES INTO THIS
MEETING WITH PRESIDENT PUTIN
WITH THE STRONG BACKING OF THE
G7 AND NATO ALLIES.
THAT